量子テレポーテーションという言葉はSFの世界の話のように聞こえるかもしれないが、今日のエピソードで話すように、
Qiskit in the Classroomでは、量子通信と
ネットワーキングに非常に実用的で役立つ技術だ。Qiskit in the Classroomへようこそ。このシリーズでは、Qiskitを使って量子コンピューティング関連コースで一般的に取り上げられる基礎的な
概念を探っていく。各動画には以下の説明欄にリンクされたインタラクティブモジュールが付いているので、
ぜひ確認してほしい。テレポーテーションは今やSFやファンタジーの
定番の比喩だ。人や物がある場所から消えて、瞬時に別の場所に現れる。
これはかっこいいが、残念ながら少なくともこの種のテレポーテーションは不可能だ。宇宙の
速度制限を破ることになる。光より速く移動できるものは何もない。しかし量子テレポーテーションは
可能だ。量子テレポーテーションでは、物質ではなく情報が二つの
離れた場所の間で伝送される。必要なのはもつれた粒子のペア、各サイトに一つずつと、二つのサイト間で古典的な
情報を通信する手段だけだ。このプロトコルは1993年にチームによって開発された。
IBMのCharles Bennettを含む量子科学者たちのチームだ。彼らがそれを量子テレポーテーションと呼んだのは、
SFバージョンと同様に、量子情報がある場所から消えて別の遠い
場所に現れ、その間の空間を通過しないからだ。魔法のように聞こえるかもしれないが、見ていくと、何も
不思議でも魔法でもない。量子もつれという現象と古典的な
通信によって可能になっている。今日は量子テレポーテーションプロトコルとその仕組みを解説する。そしてそれを
実際の量子コンピュータ上で実行して、IBMの量子プロセッサの一方の側からもう一方の側へqubitの状態をテレポートさせる。
では量子テレポーテーションの仕組みを説明しよう。二人の人物、AliceとBobが大きな距離で
隔てられているとしよう。AliceがqubitをもっているとしてそのqubitをQと呼ぼう、便宜上。そしてそれはある
未知の量子状態sqにあり、alpha 0とalpha 1は複素
数だ。Aliceは自分の状態をBobに送りたいが、qubit自体を実際に送る方法がない。Bobが
遠すぎるかもしれないし、あるいはBobがどこにいるかさえ正確にわからないので、どこに送ればいいかわからないかもしれない。幸いなことに、
二人はすでにもつれたqubitのペアAとBを共有していて、AliceはqubitAを、BobはqubitBをもっている。そして
これらのqubitはもつれている。もつれているとは、二つのqubitが大きな
距離で隔てられていても、その状態が古典物理学では説明できない方法で相関していることを意味する。このもつれたペアは
Ebitと呼ばれるもので、量子コンピューティングと通信のリソースとして使える。
この場合、AliceはEBITをリソースとして使って量子情報をBobに伝送できる。その方法を見るために、
この三つのqubitすべての結合状態を書き出すことから始めよう。qubitの順序はこの時点では多少恣意的だが、
Qiskitで実験を実行するときにこの順序が便利になる。Qiskitでは、qubitの標準的な
順序は右から左だ。つまり、qubit zeroの状態は右に現れる。
状態を少し展開してこのように書き直してみよう。そしてテレポーテーションプロトコルの最初のステップは、
AliceがCNOT gateを使って自分のデータqubitとEBIT qubitの半分をもつれさせることだ。CNOTまたはcontrolled NOT
gateは、一方のqubit（ターゲットqubit）の状態を、もう一方のqubit（コントロールqubit）の状態に応じて変える。
コントロールqubitが状態zeroにあれば、ターゲットには何も起きない。コントロールqubitが
状態oneにあれば、ターゲットqubitが反転する。この場合、AliceのデータqubitQがコントロールqubitになり、
EbitのqubitAがターゲットqubitになる。最初の二つの項はCNOTによって全く変わらなかったが、
コントロールqubitQが状態oneにあったため、最後の二つの項は変わった。次にAliceは
データqubitQにHadamard gateを適用する。これは状態0を状態1/2(0+1)に、状態1を
1/√2(0-1)に変える。ここでは簡単な代数をいくつかスキップするが、自分でやりたい人は試してみてほしい。
いくつかの項を並び替えると、このような状態が得られる。AliceとBobの三qubit
もつれ状態は完全な混乱のように見える。しかし、Aliceが両方のqubitを測定するとどうなるかを見てほしい。三
qubit状態はこれら四つの
項のうちの一つに部分的に崩壊する。それぞれの場合、Bobにはaliceの
最初の未知の状態に関連する振幅をもつ重ね合わせ状態が残る。振幅はalpha 0とalpha 1だ。例えば、
Aliceが両方のqubitをzeroと測定すれば、Bobの状態はこの項、つまりAliceがテレポートしたかった元の
未知の状態に崩壊する。しかしAliceがqubitAでzeroを、qubitQでoneを測定すれば、Bobの
状態はこれになる。この状態は、BobがZgateを適用すれば
ここの符号を反転させて元のqubitQの状態に変換できる。しかしBobは
Aliceが何を測定したかを知るまでそれをすべきかわからない。だからプロトコルの次のステップは、AliceがBobに電話して自分の
二つの測定結果を伝えることだ。それを知った後、Bobは自分のqubitに対してどの操作を行えば
Aliceの元の状態と一致するかがわかる。四つの可能な測定値と、それらの測定値に基づいてBobが
自分のqubitに対して行う必要がある四つの可能な操作の表がある。BobはZgate、Xgate、あるいは両方を
適用して自分のqubitをAliceの元のqubitに一致するよう変換する必要があるかもしれない。AliceがBobに電話するこの最後のステップが、
量子テレポーテーションが因果律を破らない理由だ。Aliceがqubitたちを測定した瞬間にBobの状態が崩壊したとしても、
AliceがBobに何を測定したかを伝えるまで、Bobはその状態から何も情報を得られない。そして
その通話は光速に制限されていた。ここまで詳細な数学を多く説明してきたので、
量子情報をテレポートしたという驚くべき事実が埋もれてしまったかもしれない。しかしこれは本当にすごいことだ。
もつれをリソースとして使うことで、Aliceは測定を行い自分のところに保存された量子情報を破壊し、それを
Bobのいる別の遠い場所に現れさせられる。この距離は何百、何千キロメートルにもなり得る。さらに
驚くべきことに、このプロトコルはAliceがBobの正確な居場所を知っている必要すらない。EbitをAliceとBobが共有し、
古典的な通信ができれば、量子テレポーテーションは機能する。では、これがどう機能するか見てみよう。
Qiskitを使って量子コンピュータで実際に量子状態をテレポートさせる。
まず3つのqubitから始める。データqubit Qと、Eビットを構成するqubit AとBをそれぞれ1つずつ用意する。
Eビットの生成から始める。qubit AにHadamardを適用し、続いて
AとBの間にCノットを適用して、目標とするエンタングル状態を生成する。
次に、このボックスに表示されたランダムなユニタリを適用して、AliceのqubitをランダムなQ量子状態に用意する。ラベルは
U。次はテレポーテーションだ。まずqubit QとAの間のCノット。次にqubit
QへのHadamard。そして測定が状態を部分的にコラプスさせ、BobのqubitだけがB重ね合わせ状態になる。
これがAliceがBobに電話をかけて、測定結果を伝えるタイミングだ。その後Bobはいくつかの
gateをその測定結果に応じて適用する。赤枠のボックスは条件付きgateを示している。最初のボックスの意味は、
qubit Aが1と測定された場合、BobがそのqubitにX gateを適用するということだ。そして
2番目のボックスは、qubit Qが1と測定された場合にもZ gateを適用するということだ。
これでBobのqubitは、ユニタリgateの後のこの時点でAliceのqubitがあったのと同じ状態になっているはずだ。
すべてが計画通りであれば、量子状態をテレポートできたということだ。ではそれをどうやって確認するか。同じ
circuitを実行するが、小さな変更を1つ加える。
ここではBobのqubitに適用するユニタリをcircuitの末尾に追加している。このユニタリは
最初にAliceのqubitに適用したものの逆演算だ。ここでの考え方は、この最初のgateが
BobのqubitにテレポートされたはずのQuantum状態を生成したなら、この逆演算でそれを元に戻し、Bobのqubitをゼロ
状態に戻せるはずだという理屈だ。ただしこれは、最初にテレポートした状態の作業をすべて元に戻してしまう。だから
テレポートした状態で実際に何かをしたい場合や、それが本当に未知の量子
状態であれば、元に戻すユニタリを適用することはできない。ともかく、これは純粋に診断目的のためで、
テレポーテーションが成功したかどうかを確認するものだ。BobのqubitがZero状態であると測定されれば、
テレポーテーションが成功したと合理的に判断できる。プロトコルが期待通りに動作していることを確認したら、この
最後のユニタリを取り除いて、テレポートした状態で実際に何かをすることができる。だが今は、動作することだけを確認しよう。
量子コンピュータでcircuitを実行しよう。Qiskit primitive samplerを使ってこのcircuitを
何度も実行し、測定結果の統計を収集できる。AliceのステートをBobへ完璧にテレポートできた場合は、
常にBobのqubitはゼロと測定されるはずだが、環境ノイズやgateの不完全さがある中では、
BobのqubitがOneになる実行もある程度見られると予想される。だが大多数の
実行でBobのqubitがゼロと測定されれば、成功と言える。ここに3つのqubitの測定結果のヒストグラムがある。Bobの測定値は各3ビット文字列の最初のスロットに表示されている。予想通り、
彼のビットがゼロに対応する4つの結果は、他の4つよりもはるかに可能性が高い。つまり、
量子状態のテレポートに成功したわけだ。ただしどれほど遠くにテレポートしたかを見てみよう。これは
使用した量子プロセッサ上のすべてのqubitのマップだ。実験では、これら3つのqubitだけを使用した。
Aliceのqubitはここにあり、Bobのqubitはここにある。つまり、ほぼ隣り合わせだった。
いくつかのswap gateを適用するだけで同じ結果を達成できたはずだ。名前が示す通り、swap gateは隣接する2つのqubitの量子状態を
入れ替えるだけだ。量子テレポーテーションは量子情報を長距離転送するのに役立つ。
量子状態はこれまでに数百キロメートル先にテレポートされた実績がある。今回の実験ではチップのサイズに制限されるが、
量子コンピュータ上の2つの離れたqubitの間で状態をテレポートすることで、テレポーテーションをもう少し印象的にすることができる。
では、試してみよう。これが新しいcircuit図だ。少し
複雑に見えるが、根本的に変わったことはない。AliceとBobが共有EBITを生成し、
その後分離するという点だけだ。この一連のラインとXはswap gateを表しており、
AliceとBobの状態を1つのqubitから別のqubitに移動させる。Aliceはqubit 1に移動し、
Bobはqubit 12に移動する。次にAliceはこのユニタリによってqubit 0上にランダムな状態を生成する。
注意してほしいのは、AliceとBobがすでに分離した後に状態を生成しているという点だ。
つまりBobはすでに彼女から遠く離れている。
テレポーテーションプロトコルはこれまで通り進み、Bobの
条件付き操作の後にAliceの元の状態を受け取る。逆ユニタリgateを適用し、BobのqubitがZero状態に
あるかどうかを確認する。そして今回も大多数の場合でBobのqubitがゼロ状態にあることが
確認された。テレポーテーションは成功だ。
ただし、AliceとBobが隣り合わせのときと比べると成功率は少し低い。それらのswap gateは
コストが高く、EBITが少し劣化する原因となる。量子テレポーテーションは魔法のように見えるかもしれないが、
エンタングルメント、古典的な通信チャネル、そして少しの巧みさがあれば実現できる。1993年に発表された元の
このビデオで扱ったプロポーザルは、量子gate テレポーテーションなどの他のプロトコルの基盤を形成し、
量子計算と量子通信に不可欠な要素となっている。
実験面では、科学者たちが量子テレポーテーションの限界を押し広げ続けており、
地球上の研究室と1,400 kmの高さにある衛星の間で光子の量子状態をテレポートすることに成功した。
また、ノイズの多い古典的なインターネットケーブルを通じて量子状態をテレポートした実績もある。自分で
量子状態をテレポートしたいなら、説明欄にリンクされた量子テレポーテーションモジュールにアクセスしてみてくれ。視聴してくれてありがとう。
次回また会おう。